cake today is not saying the exact same
things he was two years ago three years
ago five years ago he's had to evolve
some of the things he's actually said he
sort of said look
my bad on that one you know recently
came out and said hey I might even
actually get married right now whatever
so Tate's evolving right A lot of people
we talked about some of the things that
you've said they're like yeah Nick I
don't know how you're gonna beat that
one I mean all right you want these
people to die you want these people not
to be able to go to school you want
segregation all right how have your uh
not only your thoughts and your beliefs
evolved but your words
well they haven't changed much you know
because when I but isn't that an issue
if they haven't changed in six years not
necessarily because I went through a
very rapid period of change at that time
which was 2016. 2016 was an explosion of
political discourse because people don't
even think about it this way it was the
first election where he had widespread
adoption of the smartphone and social
media